Throughout the Saw franchise,
there have been many symbols and images
associated with Jigsaw,
from puzzle pieces, to
spirals, to the pigs,
which are hidden in
many of the crime scenes
in this ninth movie.
The very first victim is
targeted at a carnival,
where you can spot this
pig on the funhouse mural,
and a man holding a pig balloon.
The meaning behind the pig symbol
has changed a couple of times now.
It started as a reference
to the Year of the Pig
in the Chinese Zodiac,
which was representative
of the Eastern ideas
that Jigsaw incorporated
into his teachings,
and at some point, it became
a symbol of compassion
towards those in suffering.
JOHN: Did you know that pigs are
highly compassionate animals?
They show distress if
they see any other animal,
including humans, suffering.
- In Spiral, there's a new Jigsaw copycat,
who has a new context for
the use of the pig symbol.
It's a reference to the derogatory term
that people sometimes use
towards police officers.
The new killer is targeting dirty cops,
and so, he ironically uses
the pig costume and symbol
to give them a taste of their own-
- Brutality!
- And that's why the puppet avatar
has been changed this
time to a creepy pig.
Perhaps the dirtiest police
officer, Detective Fitch,
even has a coffee mug
decorated with pig imagery.
He discovers a pig mask shortly
before going into his trap,
and a pig falls out of the
car when the police discover
where the killer
deposited Fitch's fingers.
Other less noticeable pig symbols
include the pig models
displayed in the butcher shop
where one of the other
victims is discovered,
including this adorable little pig chef,
and the pig mask hiding in the background
as Zeke enters the church
to find Pete Dunleavy,
his number one suspect.
To learn how each trap in Spiral
evolved from one of John Kramer's traps
in the original Saw movies,
stick around to the end of this video.
This video is sponsored by Lionsgate.
Spiral is the newest
chapter in the book of Saw,
and it's now available on
digital, Blu-Ray and 4K.
If you watch my channel, you may remember
when I thought the Book of Saw
was going to be an
actual book in the movie.
That didn't age too well.
The movie stars Chris Rock, Max Minghella,
Marisol Nichols and Samuel L. Jackson.
Darren Lynn Bousman, who
directed Saw 2, 3 and 4,
is back to direct Spiral,
and I noticed some references
to some of his other work
hidden in graffiti around the city.
In addition to making movies,
he's also done these immersive
theatrical experiences.
Basically, expensive haunted
houses where you sign a waiver,
but instead of the actors
trying to scare you,
they just try to make
you really uncomfortable.
His first one was in 2016 and
called The Tension Experience,
and it's logo can be seen
graffitied on a pillar
at the 12th Street Bridge.
The next year he followed that
up with The Lust Experience,
whose logo is seen spray painted on a wall
at the courthouse.
These experiences have their own lore,
which is also referenced.
BOS stands for Brotherhood of Seraph,
a group inside The Tension
Experience universe.
The parcel delivery company
is OSDM, which stands for
Oracle Security and Data Management,
a fictional company featured
in The Lust Experience.
As is par for the Saw franchise,
there are plenty of other references
and hidden secrets to uncover,
so let's get into them.
The movie opens with the normal,
not-spooky Lionsgate logo.
I guess the new Saw films
are just not going to do that anymore.
How sad.
Detective Marv Bozwick is lured away
from the 4th of July carnival
when he chases a purse thief.
Ironically, stealing a purse
was a punishable offense
in the eyes of John Kramer in
the previous movie, Jigsaw.
When Bozwick gets down
into the subway tunnel,
he realizes he's been bamboozled
when his suspect has been
replaced by a mannequin.
That could've been his first clue
that he was dealing with a Jigsaw copycat.
You may have remembered
John's first ever workshop
in Saw 1 was in a mannequin factory.
We come to learn that the new
copycat, Detective Schenk,
believes in John Kramer's philosophy,
but has his own ideas about
who it should be applied to.
SCHENK: John Kramer was right. Spiral.
Symbol of change, evolution, progress.
But why limit that to an individual
when you can apply it to a whole system?
- So it makes sense that
a lot of Schenk's traps
seem to be evolutions of the Jigsaw traps.
The subway trap is a lot like
the classroom trap from Saw 3.
Each one requires the
victim to tear something
out of their body to escape
before time runs out.
There are also obvious parallels
to the trap from Jill's dream in Saw 7.
And yes, I prefer to call
it Saw 7 instead of Saw 3D,
so get used to it.
But I'm not actually counting this one
as an inspiration for Schenk
because it was just a dream,
we have no proof that
it was ever a real trap.
It is interesting how it
contains the Spiral logo, though.
There are a couple of red
herrings that could be placed
to lead the audience into
thinking that certain characters
are responsible for the subway trap.
Chief Banks seems to be a train fanatic,
and decorates his apartment
with pictures of locomotives,
and the drug dealer
has a 9 and 3/4 tattoo,
a reference to the famous
magical train platform
in Harry Potter.
Boz is unable to escape
the subway trap in time,
and the train that hits him
as a big IX on the front.
The Saw films have always been
labeled with Roman numerals,
and this is the numeral
for the number nine.
Spiral is the ninth film in the franchise.
Then we meet Detective Zeke Banks,
who is working undercover
with a gang of thieves,
who are in a heated
discussion about the fate
of Forrest Gump.
- I ain't see no sequel. Where's Gump 2?
- It's almost like a statement to the fans
about Mark Hoffman.
Hoffman was Jigsaw's successor,
the main villain of movies 4 through 7,
who was assumed dead
after being game over'd
in his last appearance.
He didn't appear in the
next sequel, Jigsaw.
This isn't a perfect analogy, though.
For one, there is a
sequel to Forrest Gump,
the novel just never
got a movie adaptation
like the first one did.
And for two, Josh Stolberg,
the co-screenwriter of Jigsaw and Spiral,
who is probably the most likely
candidate to write Saw 10,
has publicly tweeted about the issue,
stating that while he
didn't write the last movie
to include Hoffman, he personally
thinks that he is alive.
Speaking of Hoffman,
you'll notice this isn't
the same police station that
Hoffman annihilated in Saw 7.
That was the Metro PD 13th precinct,
while this is the South
Metro Police Station.
So we're dealing with a
different part of the same city,
but there is a nice reference
to the 13th precinct
in this movie.
Perhaps both buildings were
created by the same architect,
because the evidence room in Spiral
has a very similar layout to
the evidence room from Saw 7.
Detective Banks gets
the call to investigate
the train accident.
It's impossible to say for sure,
but is that Saw 1 director
James Wan sitting by the window
on the train?
One interesting thing about Spiral is that
nearly every previous Saw
director was involved in some way.
James Wan was an executive producer,
Darren Lynn Bousman directed it,
David Hackl was a visual consultant,
and Kevin Gruetert was
an executive producer.
That leaves the Spierig
brothers, who directed Jigsaw,
as the only Saw directors
not to work on Spiral.
However, I did find a
detail that may in fact
be a massive Jigsaw connection.
It comes when Zeke is
interrogating Bozwick's wife.
Roll it.
ZEKE: In the last few weeks,
did you notice anything unusual?
KARA: There was one thing,
there was a black SUV
parked outside
one night last week.
And he went out, and he
walked up, and I don't know,
the next thing I know, he was
yelling at somebody inside.
- This is never brought
up again in the movie,
which I find a little strange.
Jigsaw also had unanswered
questions like this.
For example, when the
pathologist, Eleanor,
makes it out of the pig
farm, she waves down a car,
then looks concerned as
she sees who's driving it.
We can't really tell if it's black,
but it does look to be
roughly the size of an SUV
Nelson also drives a gray SUV,
it could look black at night.
Maybe a future sequel
will provide the answer.
We never really get any follow-up
about Zeke's wife and kid, either,
just as Logan Nelson's kid
was a seemingly unfinished
storyline in Jigsaw.
As the police realize
they've got a Jigsaw copycat
on their hands, they study what
they know about John Kramer,
including this screenshot from Saw 4,
mugshots of Obi Tate and
Addison Corday from Saw 2,
magazine and newspaper
articles from various movies,
primarily Saw 4,
this photo of John, which is from
the Journal of Civil
Engineering, first seen in Saw 4,
and this screenshot of Billy the Puppet,
which is from the classroom trap in Saw 3.
In addition to all of that,
the cork boards contain maps
and photos from the night of
Detective Bozwick's death,
and photos of what appears
to be another crime scene
involving a knife.
This may in fact be a
leftover from a scene
that was cut from the movie.
Apparently this trap
involved someone's face
getting cut off, and they
had to submit the film to
the Motion Picture Association
11 times just to get it down
to an R-rating.
One thing I've always had fun pointing out
in my previous Saw franchise
Things You Missed episodes
is the crew referenced easter eggs,
and this scene has a few of them.
The police search Twitter for photos taken
in Stewart's Point that night for anything
that might help them to
identify the suspect.
Noel99 and NinaC aren't crew members,
but remember those names,
I'll come back to them later.
The first one is Rafael Pacheco,
a visual effects coordinator.
In the corner, there's a
prompt to follow a user
named Kiki Singh, who's probably
related to Spiral's editor,
Dev Singh.
Just a side note, I love the
idea that police work is done
by just Googling phrases related
to the date of the crime.
He just has tabs open with
searches for, "July 4 night",
"July 4 event", and "July 4 case",
as if somebody has already solved the case
and just posted the answers online.
We also get a little
glimpse of his email inbox,
where he's had exchanges with Jon C,
which is likely visual effects
supervisor Jon Campfens.
There are more names to spot
on Detective Drury's tablet,
like Nina Campfens and Noel Campfens.
They aren't listed in the credits,
but they're probably related
to VFX supervisor Jon Campfens.
You'll also see Beau Parsons.
Beau is another visual effects supervisor,
and Shawn Morris, special
effects technician, no relation.
The next police officer
to find himself in a trap
is Detective Fitch, who becomes the victim
of the finger trap.
- Help! Help me!
- If each trap is inspired
by one of the original traps
created by John Kramer,
this one definitely draws
from the electric bathtub
from Saw 5, with the source of the danger
being the combination of
water and electricity.
It's possible that this was
foreshadowed in the opening shot
of the movie, where one
of the carnival games
offers Pokemon plushies as prizes.
Specifically, you can
win Squirtle or Pikachu,
the water type and the electric
type Pokemon, respectively.
The ferris wheel was even blue and yellow.
Amanda would be rocking
out if she was still here.
The finger trap begins at
the sound of the buzzer,
(BUZZ)
which sounds exactly like the
buzzer from the pig vat trap
in Saw 3.
(BUZZ BUZZ)
We hear the sound again later
on in the glass grinder trap,
where it's used to signal the beginning
of the flying glass shards.
The finger trap is designed to take away
Fitch's overactive trigger fingers.
It's interesting to see an actual Saw trap
that takes away your fingers,
because the poster for Saw 2 features
a pair of severed fingers,
but there's no finger-severing
scene in the movie,
so I guess it was a long time coming.
The trap also takes place
at a location called
the Nesbitt Brothers' Breads.
Michael Nesbitt is the movie's
assistant art director.
Not having heard from his father,
Zeke goes to his
apartment to check on him.
He comes across the old
photo of him and his dad
at Constantine's Hobby Shop.
This is another crew reference easter egg.
Jason Constantine was one of
Spiral's executive producers.
A new package containing
another flash drive
is delivered to the police
station the next day,
and we get a short glimpse
of Zeke's computer screen
before he plugs it in.
It seems he's looking up
an event from 11/11/2004,
where two males got into
a fight in a parking lot.
I don't think this report is
relevant to the story at all,
as these descriptions don't match
any important Saw characters,
but I would note that
this would've been a matter of weeks after
the bathroom game in Saw 1.
The date 11/11 is also
significant for the director
Darren Lynn Bousman, who
directed a horror film titled
11/11/11, about strange
events occurring on that date.
The clues lead Zeke and
Schenk to investigate
this meth dealer who may
have ties to their suspect.
SING: Think we have enough
for a warrant, though?
TAPP: Who said anything about a warrant?
SCHENK: Don't we need a warrant for this?
ZEKE: What're you talking about?
- The whole scene is
packed with easter eggs
from Saw 4 and 5.
You can tell we're about
to get into a throwback
when they enter the
grimy apartment building
with the green tinge,
the signature aesthetic
of the first seven films.
I'm first reminded of Officer Rigg's foray
into the Alexander Motel in Saw 4,
where he blows by a morbidly
obese man in a tank top
to go up the stairs.
Here, we see Zeke and Schenk do the same.
At the top of the stairs,
there's a room completely
illuminated in red,
just like the room where
Rigg finds the evidence
in the motel.
On the way up the stairs,
Zeke is confronted
by an aggressive dog.
- Whoa, whoa, whoa! Shit! Get your dog!
Get your fucking dog!
- This is almost like a perfect
reenactment of the scene
at Mark Hoffman's apartment in Saw 5.
- Heel! Heel, I said! Don't provoke him!
Asshole!
Jesus Christ, come on, Peewee. Come on!
- Another Saw trope brought
back in Spiral is the idea
of the killer being disguised
as a victim of the game.
In Saw 1 it was John,
in Saw 2 it was Amanda,
in Saw 4 it was Hoffman,
and in Jigsaw it was Nelson.
This time, Detective Schenk
makes it appear as if
he's been killed, only to
reveal that he did this
by leaving his tattoo on
the real victim's arm.
There's also a nice detail
in this scene, where they go
to interrogate Pete.
Pete is the one who shot Schenk's father,
and Schenk stays back behind
his partner out of fear
of possibly being recognized,
even though he was just a kid
when they last met.
The next victim is the
police captain, Angie Garza.
She is trapped inside the evidence room by
the pig-masked Schenk.
It makes sense, because only
a police officer would be able
to get into this room.
The door to the evidence room is secured
by Vincent and Jules Safe Company.
If that sounds familiar, it's
because Vincent and Jules
are the two main characters
in the 1994 crime movie,
Pulp Fiction.
Jules was played by
actor Samuel L. Jackson,
who also plays Chief
Marcus Banks in Spiral.
Marcus Banks is the father of Zeke Banks,
and the only character to
call him by his full name.
- Ezekiel.
- This may be a reference to Pulp Fiction,
where one of the most famous scenes
features Samuel L. Jackson
quoting a Bible verse
called Ezekiel 25:17.
Anyway, Captain Garza is
put into the wax trap,
which will smother her face in hot wax
if she's unable to sever her spinal cord
with the blade under her neck.
It's not really clear how
this trap works mechanically,
but there are a number of
Jigsaw traps that share
the same concept of drowning
or smothering the victim
if they can't complete their task on time,
from the pig vat in Saw 3,
to the water cube in Saw 5,
to the silo in Jigsaw.
With those that he has deemed
to be bad cops out of the way,
Schenk is ready for the finale
of his plan and kidnaps Zeke,
who awakens chained to a pipe.
Obviously this is a
callback to the beginning
of the first movie, so I'm
not even going to count that
on the Things You Missed,
but after escaping,
he discovers Pete, who is caught
in the last Jigsaw-inspired
trap, the glass grinder.
This one is just like the
freezer room from Saw 3.
The only difference is
that instead of the victim
being sprayed with freezing water
while someone tries to find
the key to set them free,
Pete is getting sliced
apart by shards of glass.
Schenk's hideout is in an
abandoned soap factory.
This is another common
trait shared with Jigsaw,
who always used abandoned
factories as his hideouts
and locations for his games.
It even has the obligatory sliding door,
although nobody says the
iconic line, "Game over"
in this one.
The final trap is the puppet
trap, where Chief Banks
is hung up on strings,
and Zeke must decide
between saving him or killing Schenk.
This one isn't really
inspired by a Jigsaw trap,
from what I can tell,
but the explanation of the
trap is definitely familiar.
Roll it.
- You know there's 1.5 gallons of blood
in the human body, Zeke?
At the rate your old man's bleeding out,
in just three minutes,
those jars will be full,
and your dad will be dead.
- The human body, for instance,
is an astoundingly durable creation.
It contains approximately
10 pints of blood,
yet it is still able to
operate with just half of that.
- 10 pints is only equal to 1.25 gallons.
I looked it up, and I
guess the average body has
1.2 to 1.5 gallons of blood,
so they're kind of both right,
in a way.
This trap not only takes
place behind this wall
graffitied with Jigsaw's spiral symbol,
but it's also located at the
top of a spiral staircase.
Well, kind of.
After a classic Saw-style
montage, Detective Schenk,
or if we're calling him by his
real name, William Emerson,
slips away in an elevator,
just as Jigsaw did way back
in Darren Lynn Bousman's
first Saw movie, Saw 2.
I want to give a big thanks to Lionsgate
for sponsoring this video.
Check out the link in the description
to purchase your own copy of Spiral.
But to fully understand the world of Saw,
you'll need to click
that playlist on the left
for Thing You Missed episodes
on every single movie.
Remember, subscribe to CZsWorld
for new horrors every week,
and ring that death bell
for all notifications,
and I'll see you in the next
one, assuming we both survive.